c'est une première dans l'épreuve des 80
km de les contrer la participation d'un
para triathlète vice-champion de france
2 paratriathlon brice marmonnier
s'élancer sur cette épreuve samedi 16
mars avec un soutien pour l'association
entraide une lame pour courir objectif
sensibiliser à l'appareillage des
enfants amputés pour faire du sport 80e
c'est plein d'incertitudes
surtout quand il est amputé déjà accordé
valide c'est une grosse distance et là
on a encore pu t il faut gérer les
prothèses
il faut gérer le physique je vais
préparer assidûment en même temps que ma
complète il met à ma saison
internationale de triathlon et abat
aujourd'hui je suis là pour relever le
défi
brice marc money a terminé l'épreuve en
2h34 pour cette douzième édition ils
étaient deux mille sept cents
participants avec le traditionnel départ
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines finir les six possibles en
huit heures dans huit heures ça serait
bien
on voit gil jourdan la tour eiffel
comment nommer les rendez-vous au
premier étage du genre 44 comme ça
l'objectif c'est de faire 10h10 heure
et voilà en tout cas arrivé avant demain
c'est ça notre on arrive samedi
l'ambition pour nous c'est de faire
découvrir le trail et sur tout le
territoire naturel de la région
ile-de-france et la richesse du
patrimoine aussi le patrimoine
historique parce qu'il ya des lieux qui
sont vraiment absolument méconnu est
vraiment chouette à découvrir donc c'est
aussi ça qu'on veut offrir au courant
pour cette douzième édition benoît
corrie est arrivé en tête au premier
étage de la tour eiffel avec un temps de
5 heures 46 minutes